let's talk about saturday again okay so
do you think that um
um the style bender is um
because people are saying he's goat
right
that's a that's that when people throw
that out there's
been so many great eras in the sport you
know i mean
and um he is very unique
right how do you place him in the middle
of way in terms of middleweight
um fighters yeah well i mean he's the
champion of the world right now
right so he's number one and rightly so
i mean if you look at who he's beaten
and how he beats them you know i mean
i'll be honest prior to saturday night i
was kind of
and he'll tell you because we've had
conversations about this he's called me
out on it you know whenever because
prior to commentating i still do it a
bit now i do the pre in the post fight
shows and we have to make predictions on
who's going to win and stuff like that
and i picked him to lose a few times and
every time he goes out there
and proves me wrong right and then we
bumped into each other and i
you know i said to her i said oh i'm
sorry man because fighters take it very
[ __ ] personal oh yeah you know what i
mean when i go on tv or whoever it is
i remember when i used to fight and i'd
be in the locker room and they have the
pre-show
on the tv you know and you'll see
whoever it is and they're talking about
yeah he's gonna lose second round
knockout i think you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah all right see you later
it does irk you a little bit and you
think i'll have a word with that guy
so anyway you know uh and i always
thought
well there always was a reason for why
he was winning right the reason was he
was very good but i guess robert
whittaker robert whitaker had a terrible
game plan he kept lunging him from
something from so far away
so i was like oh yeah yeah yeah robert
whitaker was [ __ ] and then i was like i
get sanders and silver it wasn't the
most
it wasn't the busiest fight right i was
like well you know anderson didn't
really do much you know
i feel if he stepped on the gas more
then he could have beaten israel
and then yo romero you all didn't do
[ __ ] all my oh come on that fight didn't
even happen
but the fact of the matter is like
bartending it cost a saturday night he
went out there and he didn't do much
either
right but it it when a pattern starts to
form
you can't sit there and say it's not
because he's that good when the pan
starts to form it's because
like costa saturday night was scared
yeah he didn't want to
get in the punching range in the pocket
as they called it because
at a sudden he was too fast he was just
too fast and any time he went near he
was like oh
[ __ ] yeah they got my head taken off
there yeah so it's easy for me to just
stand there in the middle of the octagon
and let you dictate the dance yeah kick
the [ __ ] out of me so it's not
israel it's not his fault that his
opponents are scared of him
i also kind of picked up on that even
like in the pre-fight or
before the fight like leading up to it
how he was already kind of tentative and
he seemed a little bit emotional
martina right yeah yeah it's it's those
very emotional especially now
yeah yeah oh no what happened he cried
no today like he saw the video
no don't tell me what happened well
israel kind of gave him a little dry
hump
i loved it in the octagon i loved it but
he wasn't aware of that because he was
just knocked out yeah
yeah you don't like the video yeah yeah
and he's like [ __ ] it
okay show me the fight she
okay oh [ __ ] man here and then it's like
what the [ __ ] he did
what yeah so yeah he's pissed he's
putting out some video
well he's calling for a rematch
immediately crazy because you're never
gonna get a rematch because you've got
your ass kicked he's gotta win probably
four
more times right he's got to beat
cannonier he's got to be
there's a bunch of guys out there yeah
yeah yeah sure yeah he's not getting a
rematch
i think whitaker you know although
people think that
um he got his ass kicked but i think
whittaker
deserves another shot don't you probably
because he whitaker had like one
how many times did he defend at
whittaker well no no because he was
never the real champ
or he wasn't it was it was interesting
yeah there was some weird
weird thing yeah yeah people missing
weight and [ __ ] well it was it wasn't
his fault to be fair but he did beat a
lot of good guys and he
beat joel a few times yeah and he just
beat darren till and he's fighting
jared cannon here we're kind of near
yeah the winner of that should fight
who's a beast
oh yeah near it don't you think oh yeah
no absolutely absolutely yeah yeah yeah
yeah
very very yeah whitaker fought a sonya
i it seemed like i love whitaker he's my
favorite fighter for years
we just like his um demeanor he's very
humble
a nice guy yeah he's a very nice guy
yeah yeah um
but it seemed like a total he seemed
like
unmatched like you couldn't get in there
at all yeah
yeah and i just like before at the time
when i watched it initially i'm like oh
well
whitaker didn't show up did it hear the
terrible game plan he kept trying to
lunge in and again that's not
uh israel's fault that's because they
were scared and intimidated because he's
so tall he's so long and he's so fast
and every time he was trying to get on
the inside
to land the shot it was like whoa yeah
so then i'm going to start acting
desperate
trying to land these big wild shots yeah
which just leaves you more
open to get counted yeah he has
length you know i mean oh yeah he's a
long fighter right he's also
kind of scrawny but he really is precise
like those kicks that he did on apollo
costa barcinia what's his name
that's his nickname yeah but that's
who's his real what's his real last
night how long costa yeah you said it
three times no no you said it
why did he well why was he called
boroccini because everybody has a
nickname
yeah oh i thought they said bobby slept
king
that slept as my yeah yeah bobby the
slap king right then i just changed it
back to lee
is that what happened what no bobby the
slept king lee
yeah yeah but before he he wasn't just
oh that's right he didn't he wasn't
listed as paul acosta he wasn't before
he used to fight as
paolo
on instagram not on twitter you got to
follow it it's hilarious what is it some
of your friends freak
uh are featured on there regularly yeah
it's a parody mma account
but you know they like to make for
anyone who misspeaks
they get they they get they get a little
roasting on there it's funny there's a
lot of tealts a lot of brendan sharp
but it's funny it's good clean fun but
they just they just highlight when
people [ __ ] up and
it's funny i don't know why it's called
boccinia depot but right yeah but give
it a follow